economía en france 24 saludo a mi
compañera daniela blandón daniela muy
buenas noches comenzamos hablando de esa
suspensión de las negociaciones en eeuu
para un segundo paquete de ayudas que
van entonces a continuar después de las
elecciones sigan thiago buenas noches
pues cuando inició la pandemia el
congreso aprobó la inyección de 3
billones de dólares a la economía la
mayoría de esos recursos fue repartida
en cheques a quienes se quedaron sin
empleo pero cuando expiró la ayuda en
julio comenzaron a negociar otro paquete
que el mercado estaba esperando con
muchas ansias pero no hubo consenso
entre republicanos y demócratas el
presidente de donald trump anunció hoy
la suspensión de las conversaciones
hasta después de elecciones en su cuenta
de twitter dijo que nancy pelosi está
pidiendo 2,4 billones de dólares para
rescatar a los estados demócratas mal
administrados y con alto nivel de
delincuencia pero que este dinero no
está relacionado con kobe 19 agregó que
hizo una oferta muy generosa de 16
billones de dólares pero que pelosi no
estaban negociando de buena fe
inmediato recibió críticas no sólo de la
propia pelosi quien dijo que la casa
blanca es un completo desorden sino
también de la reserva federal que afirma
que la economía estará en riesgo si no
se entregan más ayudas hablemos ahora de
américa latina' porque la cepal dice que
la recuperación de nuestra región va a
ser más lenta de lo previsto
bueno ya se sabe de santiago que la
región vive su peor crisis económica en
un siglo según este organismo lo nuevo
es que la cepal cree que la recuperación
no va a ser tan fácil y tomará por lo
menos tres años es decir será mucho más
lenta de lo que fue en la gran depresión
de la década del 30 para este año se
espera una caída del pib regional del
9.1 por ciento y que la economía pierda
una década de avance con más de 27
millones de empresas cerradas el año
podría cerrar con 44 millones de
desempleados pero también con 231
millones de pobres de los cuales 96
millones estarán en la pobreza extrema a
santiago seguimos hablando de américa
latina' hablemos ahora de argentina y
llegó una
del fondo monetario internacional de
este país el martes para negociar sí
pues el objetivo es de renegociar un
acuerdo de reestructuración de deuda que
es más o menos santiago lo mismo que
pasó con acreedores privados hace unas
semanas en total 44 mil millones de
dólares en juego producto de un préstamo
que recibió el país en 2018 durante la
administración de mauricio macri el
fondo monetario internacional no es bien
visto en este país porque esa misma
época pues fue la que desató la recesión
por eso en buenos aires hubo
manifestaciones este martes esta semana
los representantes del fondo se reunirán
con el gobierno también con el congreso
empresarios y sector privado al final el
objetivo es reprogramar los pagos de
esta millonaria suma ya veremos los
resultados de esa negociación daniel
hablemos ahora de la policía española
que detuvo al millonario que es el
creador del antivirus mcafee sí pues
creo que todos los conocemos santiago y
desconocido bastante pues el magnate
estadounidense george makeup y es él
creador de este antivirus que también
lleva su nombre pero ha sido bastante
polémico y en eeuu la justicia lo señala
por los delitos de estafa y evasión de
impuestos las autoridades creen que ganó
más de 23 millones de dólares
promoviendo cripto monedas falsas ya
hemos hablado de estas inversiones con
orden de interpol
el empresario fue capturado en el
aeropuerto de barcelona antes de abordar
un avión hacia estambul pero esta no es
la primera vez que tiene que responder
ante la justicia en julio del año pasado
fue arrestado en república dominicana
con varias armas a bordo de su yate
los indicadores como lo fue las bolsas
hoy bueno lo que inició como una jornada
de avances en wall street terminó con
caídas debido a la suspensión de
negociaciones de un segundo paquete de
estímulos todas bajaron más del 1 por
ciento las bolsas europeas no alcanzaron
a reaccionar al anuncio de última hora y
casi todas cerraron con ganancias y en
américa latina hubo cierres en mixtos en
argentina el mercado no tuvo reacciones
bruscas a esta visita del fm cifra el de
apreciar que nos tiene
en 1800 por ciento en esto crecieron las
importaciones de máscaras faciales en
europa en el primer trimestre del 2020
éstas pasaron de 800 millones de euros a
14 mil millones de euros debido por
supuesto a la pandemia pero le tengo un
dato adicional luxemburgo bélgica y
alemania fueron las que más compraron
estos elementos por habitante le dejó la
tarea cuántas mascarillas usted al día
gracias daniela esto en el modo por el
momento aquí en economía france24 siga
con nosotros
[Música]